if there's anything that recent years
have sadly taught us it's that diseases
are an insidious and formidable enemy
that can take you by surprise
whether it's bacterial a virus a fungal
infection or even an unfortunate genetic
mutation like cancer alzheimer's or
multiple sclerosis sometimes dealing
with a dangerous pathogen could leave
you praying for a run-in with scp-682
after all at least getting devoured by a
giant evil reptile is a quick death
but take a page out of the scp
foundation's book sometimes the best
response to an imminent threat is
containment and research one of the
first rules of combat is to know your
enemy it may seem like a tall order to
have to write the book on dangerous
diseases but thankfully that book has
already been written it's scp-1025
the encyclopedia of common diseases this
handy reader-friendly volume will tell
you everything you need to know about
all the common maladies you may find
yourself facing and a whole lot more
from the sniffles to lung cancer from a
cold sore to necrotizing fasciitis you
may be thinking why would i need some
dusty old book to tell me about diseases
i can always just go to webmd but you
don't want that you know what the
internet is like they'll just tell you
you're sick and you don't want them
putting silly ideas in your head like
that how about you open up to a random
page and we'll take a look there see the
common cold classic let's see the
description the common cold is a virus
that affects the upper respiratory tract
its duration is typically a maximum of
two weeks and its primary symptoms
include headaches muscle aches a cough a
runny nose raised temperature pressure
in the ears or face and loss of taste or
smell see simple straightforward and
objective exactly what you need
did you just cough
that's strange
and come to think of it your nose is
looking a little red do you need a
tissue or perhaps a throat lozenge your
voice seems a little hoarse perhaps you
ought to take a break and lay down you
really don't look so good seems like the
common cold to us thankfully you
shouldn't have to worry about it for
more than two weeks oh and that reminds
me there is a certain anomalous effect
to the encyclopedia of common diseases
whenever you read about a pathogen in
the encyclopedia of common diseases you
catch it manifesting even its most
severe symptoms in an extremely brief
period of time of course this isn't that
much of a problem if you just read the
article about having a sore throat or a
stomach bug but what if you read the
page for ebola suddenly you're half dead
and bleeding from the eyes or the
bubonic plague or a disease that
humanity has never even faced before and
what if worst of all the people who
catch the diseases from this book
continue to be contagious to others it
could be the basis for a
world-destroying biological weapon and
at the very least a bonafide keter class
anomaly when the scp foundation got
their hands on this little hardcover
anomalous nightmare the researchers
handling this thing realized it needed
to be kept under lock and key a new
provisional site was created just to
contain and research it without the risk
of its anomalous effects starting an
unstoppable global pandemic the base was
an isolated underground bunker
containing an even more high security
containment unit to store the book
itself a vault surrounded by at least 10
armed guards at any given time rotated
twice weekly and checked for any
infectious agents there was even a
powerful thermite bomb stored beneath
the vault set to go off and annihilate
the entire chamber if the plausible risk
of a containment breach was detected it
may seem insane to put in this many
security failsafes for a simple
anomalous book but the scp foundation
has dealt with dangerous books before
take scp-140 also known as an incomplete
chronicle this dangerous historical
volume chronicles the living history of
the davites an extinct culture of
sadistic sorcerers closely tied to the
mythos of the scarlet king whenever ink
or blood is brought into the presence of
this book it absorbs the material
expanding the davite history and
bringing their terrifying rule ever
closer to the modern day or take
scp-3512 the more you know a pickup
artist's bible a deadly instruction
manual made by a mind controlling group
of interests known as the fithists this
book gave its sinister practitioners the
tools to control the minds of their
potential romantic partners often
leading to their deaths while it may not
be quite as apocalyptic as
scp-1025 or scp-140
the fact that there are so many in
circulation still makes it a dangerous
threat point is a book can be a
dangerous thing especially if its pages
have the potential to unlock deadly
diseases like scp-1025
as you can expect with an infectious
ketter class anomaly of this magnitude
procedures around this one were rigorous
the side staff was a skeleton crew
observing strict quarantine procedures
to prevent any potential infection from
leaking out into the wider world
research into the history of the book
was inconclusive despite a bevy of
foundation resources being poured into
finding any worthwhile leads on the
author or publisher of the book nothing
it was an absolute mystery who or what
had put this xk class end of the world
scenario waiting to happen here on earth
but now it was the job of these intrepid
researchers to discover the full extent
of its potential dangers 27 d-class
subjects were allocated to the base for
testing by the time the process was over
none of these unlucky prisoners would
remain alive the test started much like
this video the researchers forced a
d-class to read the section on the
common cold within two hours the subject
began coughing upon being asked they
also reported feeling physically achy
though they attributed the egg to
sleeping on an uncomfortable d-class cot
every night the researchers were
concerned already the incubation period
for the common cold meaning the period a
person is infected before showing active
symptoms can be as long as three days
two hours is unprecedented next d-class
was told to read the section on
chickenpox a common childhood malady
that can be considerably more dangerous
in adulthood within an hour of being
exposed the d-class repeatedly scratched
no less than five points on her body
repeatedly while she claimed that this
was because of the itchy d-class
jumpsuits it was too eerily close to a
symptom of chickenpox to be ignored the
medical history of this d-class also
showed that she'd suffered chickenpox in
childhood suggesting that scp-1025
infections have the power to override
previous immunities next things got a
little more serious they tested the
section on lung cancer on a d-class with
no family history of lung conditions not
long after the researchers noted that
the d-class coughed an unusual number of
times not only that they picked up
irregularities in the d-class's
breathing that appeared to be
characteristic of lung cancer while the
d-class did not report any feelings of
chest pain or discomfort the researchers
had him terminated and dissected no
tumors were found a researcher noted
that they didn't wait long enough for
proper tumor manifestation they knew
they heard that d-class coughing the
researchers were so concerned by the
results of the previous test they
repeated it exactly with another d-class
who they then observed over a period of
seven days to track tumor manifestation
researchers made a note of an unusual
amount of coughing and wheezing from the
subject over this period of time the
d-class was then terminated and
dissected but surprise surprise
no tumors researchers began to consider
the frightening possibility that signs
of scp-1025
illnesses disappear after the victims
die
meaning that a pandemic started by
scp-1025 would be impossible to properly
track and respond to things were only
getting scarier and scarier for the
scp-1025 researchers sequestered away in
that isolated foundation bunker
researchers continued to delve further
into the lung cancer rabbit hole this
time however they didn't wait for the
subject to die before looking at their
insides they instead performed a
vivisection on the subject only to find
that despite the victims still being
alive and displaying some of the key
symptoms of lung cancer there were no
tumors what could this mean these
diseases weren't behaving like any of
their non-anomalous counterparts what
other differences could we be dealing
with here infectious lung cancer and
what if there are more books out there
like time bonds just waiting to go off
the tests continued getting more
isolated and more intense in the end the
scp-1025 site was staffed by only three
researchers and two agents acting as
guards d-classes were sent in one by one
to minimize ration requirements it
seemed that they could have been dealing
with one of the most dangerous anomalies
of all time even working with it could
be a trigger for the apocalypse if the
proper containment and quarantine
procedures weren't observed things got
so out of hand that a d-class without an
appendix was told to read the section on
appendicitis and researchers still
observed him exhibiting symptoms of the
condition he was vivisected and while
the appendix was still not present the
organs in the area where the appendix
would have been seemed redder than usual
when would this nightmare end well it
would actually end much sooner than
anyone involved would anticipate despite
never even reading scp-1025 himself a
researcher developed a strange
persistent cough and was quarantined in
a containment chamber by his concerned
colleagues on the seventh day of his
containment he seemed to be slightly
taller than before a symptom of scp-016
a deadly anomalous bloodborne pathogen
that multiplies wildly and rewrites the
genetic structure of its hosts if placed
into a high stress situation this led to
a number of terrifying revelations not
only did the book have the potential to
inflict a number of anomalous diseases
but it could also potentially do so by
pure proximity even if you don't
actually read it what other anomalous
diseases could be on the table now what
about
scp-008 a terrifying prion with both 100
virality and 100 lethality or scp-742
a retrovirus that slowly but surely
transforms its victims into
cannibalistic monsters or even the
horrifying scp-270
the disease that slowly converts your
entire body into a mechanical nightmare
there would be no limit the horrors
scp-1025 could unleash on the world if
it ever got out they needed to keep this
thing locked up at any cost that's when
the infected researcher escaped and all
hell broke loose the isolated facility
went dark for 72 hours after not being
able to get into contact with any other
foundation bases during that time a
recovery team was sent to investigate
the mystery one agent and one researcher
were found in the observation booth
wearing biological containment suits
another agent was found crawling through
the air ducts with this handgun drawn a
crazed look in his eye an additional
researcher had locked himself in the
barracks with a homemade flamethrower
paranoid about infection and the final
agent was found dead in a storage locker
with some empty bottles and ration
packages after having given the door an
airtight seal to prevent infection then
dying of suffocation inside the o5
council shuttered the entire
investigation
scp-1025 was downgraded from ketter to
safe class then placed in a storage
locker the whole thing was considered a
wash we know what you're probably
wondering why if this anomaly was so
incredibly dangerous why on earth would
the o5 council and the rest of the
foundation be dealing with it so
casually well that's simple the initial
batch of researchers had grievously
misjudged the actual anomalous effect of
scp-1025
it doesn't give diseases to those who
read its text instead it induces a form
of hypochondria by proxy to those around
the reader in other words while scp-1025
has no effect on the reader it makes
everyone around them merely believe that
they've come down with a terrible
illness the few members of staff in that
isolated site had been killing and
dissecting d-classes for no reason in
effect they had all effectively gone mad
due to the anomalous effects of scp-1025
and the paranoia induced by pressure and
isolation much like your average
hypochondriac they warped the data to
fit the worst possible outcome rather
than the most mundane and likely as an
old medical expression goes when you see
hoof prints think horses not zebras the
entire thing had been a terrifying waste
of time money and human life so perhaps
in the end the encyclopedia of common
diseases is a lot more like webmd than
we thought it's not nearly as useful as
getting a consultation with an actual
doctor and of course it's liable to put
some very strange ideas in your head now
go check out
scp-2852 sadistic madman party crasher
cousin johnny and
scp-701 the hanged king's tragedy for
more scps that'll drive you to madness